- And now think about this okay,
every single you know
from Dolly, every single.
- Yeah.
- She wrote.
- I know!
- That's impossible, first of all.
- [Kelly] I know.
(audience applauding)
- And the fact that
they're fabulous songs.
- And some of those are classics,-
- Oh, I'm telling you.
- that will stand time.
Yeah.
- There is no...
I'm not sure there's any
greater country song.
Once it gets to a certain level.
He stopped loving her today.
- Oh.
- All the songs are kind
of in that same category.
- Yeah, yeah.
- "Jolene".
- And to have Jolene,
this woman talking about,
you're gonna take my man and
you look like Dolly Parton.
- Yeah, like what did she look like?
- Right, exactly.
So the tenderness or the
fragileness she shows in there.
- Yeah.
- And when she sings it, you believe it.
- Yeah, a storyteller.
- That's...
- She's, she's unbelievable,
and I...
- That's what's great though.
That's why I hadn't,
y'all haven't done a song.
Y'all hadn't done anything together,
which shocks me.
- No.
- 'Cause you're both
incredible storytellers.
Like, that's why I was like,
I can't believe this is the first time...
But what a way to come out,
the first time y'all do something,
host something together.
That's incredible.
- She was very sweet.
I remember when I got
the call and I'm going,
"I'm talking to Dolly Parton".
I just couldn't believe
it, because I'm such a fan.
(Kelly laughing)
Right, you know?
- What?
(audience laughing)
- And the thing is we
always talk about the goat.
- Yeah.
- And the goat is always a guy.
- Oh, I get that.
- I'm not sure that the goat,
of country music isn't a female.
- Yeah, I like to hear it!
(audience cheering and applauding)
(hands clapping)
Well, I guess-
- She's amazing.
- it's subjective too,
because, like when people think of a goat
it's probably subjective who in your mind,
like really stands out and
holds that crown, right?
- Right.
- Like so I will say like, you
are the goat for many people.
Also, your wife might be the goat.
- [Garth] Oh my wife, there's my wife.
(audience clapping and cheering)
I think she's amazing.
- I know,
I know you know, my obsession with Trisha.